Bienvenue module to dare to fool us
quote on the caleche cup of tea asaji
possible masala packet to his ma a
transparent uncle's what we do
conference depress consecutive la
première avec president this president
executive man investigate a low
commission vote on ecology dongseong
will be pi K is a demotion economy we
just apply indigent confirm of the price
of a medium yet leaders you and son a
valley on purely accommodation a
orientation through specific adopters or
via a commission just a technical
reminder for all of us and for you in
particular and your colleagues as you
know we've introduced a new system to
manage these press conferences we will
continue to pass you the floor when we
give you the floor your name will turn
blue on your screen you press the speak
button you become red you speak and once
you've asked your question please press
the button again so that we have no echo
in the room with that missus well thank
you very much it has been it has been a
long and very difficult spring key
workers in health care and other vital
services they have worked tirelessly and
selflessly to keep us safe and we've had
to make changes in the way we live our
lives to help contain the spread of the
virus but we're slowly starting to
emerge from a life beyond lock down
though not yet a life beyond the
coronavirus our thought so now I think
turning to summer and maybe even further
and to the places that we love to travel
that be by the sea
the mountains our cities and our
countryside and those places they are
keen to welcome back
travelers tourism is a vital part of
Europe's economy nearly a tenth of GDP
across Europe and more than ten percents
in 11 member states millions of jobs
depends on tourism and that often in
areas where there aren't many other
industries and tourism gives those
regions both security and hope for all
that work there but we have to
reintroduce it safely so this is the
first fundamental principles of the
packages that we present today safety
that underlies our guidance and that
means taking gradual careful steps to
help travel restart in line with what
science tells us the second principle
allow guidance is no discrimination
different countries of course are in
different situations but we need to
treat Europeans equally and we all share
that responsibility governments and
businesses workers and travelers and the
most important thing is that we are open
about what we know and what we don't
know this is the only way for travellers
and businesses to take informed
decisions and obviously no one should
travel if feeling sick or having
symptoms we need to work together to
keep travel safe as Europe starts to
cross borders again and that is why the
European Commission has adopted this
package of guidance and recommendations
today to coordinate a safe return to
travel and tourism this summer the
package is built on the joint European
roadmap towards lifting
and it's about coordinating not
replacing the work that is being done by
businesses by national and local
governments all over Europe we've seen
all kinds of innovative ideas to help
tourism recover that could be phone
numbers websites like in Greece Germany
or Austria that inform tourist
businesses about how to operate safely
or the project in Lithuania and Slovakia
that allows customer to bow by vouchers
to support their favorite pubs and
restaurants and they are bound to be
more good ideas to come so our guidance
doesn't try to prescribe exactly what
governments and businesses should do
instead it's about coordinating the
steps that are taken throughout Europe
so that travelers and workers can feel
confident and safe there are four vital
areas that our guidance addresses this
is to enable tourism in a safe way this
summer obviously travel water health and
vouchers first we need carefully
reopened borders within Europe so we
have adopted guidance for member states
on a gradual coordinated lifting of
restrictions on the free movements in
Europe second people need of course to
be able to travel between European
countries so we're giving guidance on
how to gradually reopen transport links
without risking the health of travelers
or transport workers third travellers
and workers they need to know that the
places that tourism visits but they are
safe hotels restaurants beaches other
tourist sites they need to be run in a
way that minimizes the risk of passing
on the coronavirus so with the help of
the European Centre for disease
prevention and control we've put
together health
and safety guidance with concrete
examples that explains how to operate
these services in a safe way and finally
we do not get very far if businesses
like hotels and airlines they have gone
out of business and yet a lot of these
businesses they are feeling an intense
strain they're caught between the needs
to refund canceled trips and the reality
that new bookings are still very thin on
ground the starting point here is that
European consumers have a right to a
cash refund if that is what they want
. many companies have come under
pressure and this liquidity crunch would
be less severe if customers accepted
vouchers instead of cash refunds so
today we adopt the recommendation on how
to make these vouchers more attractive
for consumers to accept at the same time
many more companies are in a situation
where liquidity is very tight on 19th of
march we adopted the temporary framework
post a date which allows member states
to provide liquidity support very
quickly very simply and many governments
now all over europe have stepped in to
help companies also in the tourism
industry to help them mitigate the
crisis with a lot of liquidity today's
guidance can give a chance of a better
season for the many europeans whose
livelihood depends on tourism and of
course for those who would like to
travel this summer but that will only
work if each and every one of us do our
part in the last few weeks we have all
gotten used to the idea that the health
of our whole community depends on our
responsible choices
but also that there are different
unjustified recommendation in member
states that we should respect for
instance on whether and where to use
face masks or how many meters is
considered a safe distance between
travelers and guests in restaurants and
when we begin to travel again we need to
keep that in mind that there are
differences and they are justified to
keep that in mind we need information
and that will be my last point and in
order to have information the Commission
is coordinating the work with member
states to make sure that for instance
voluntary contract tracing apps what
will and respect our privacy and indeed
that they will work across Europe the
Commission has also decided to set up a
website with an interactive map so that
Europeans have the confidence to travel
knowing what is happening in the
countries that they are visiting of
course this is not going to be a normal
summer not for any of us but when we all
work together and we all do our part in
the way the Commission is setting out
today then we don't have to face a
summer struck at home or a completely
lost summer for the European tourist
industry Thank You Julie
souvenir some do it in diversity GE
artistry L follow up today twice you a
vocal organization model the result when
you declare the hot to do well episode
the upon de demócrata
likely the carnival is now at the menina
port on the metronome set strategy
contra and half of the necessity the
definition song in the veteran economy
prepare
you numeric you easily art it's avoid
Edom or OC poor a sector du tourisme
accommodation can you adopt or job Jesus
clear yeah don't let do the perspective
even one decision likely is that where
it actually a telepath our sample area
you have today number of Commissioners
presenting the different elements of the
package to you today so I we try to be
very brief
millions of SMEs and family-run
businesses working in accommodation
restaurants passenger transport and
travel agencies risk language said
bankruptcies and job losses that's a
reality of this ecosystem they urgently
need to go back to work and they're all
willing to go back to work
and we are all a gently needing them to
go back to work because our entire
Europe economy depend on our ability to
go back to work at the same time as
individuals we all need a great salad a
break especially after this confinement
we wanted to enjoy some early days we
would like to see our families and
friends even if they live in another
region in another country this is a case
for you and for me Robert but we want to
be able to do so while staying healthy
and safe because we know that the virus
will stay with us for some time it's a
difficult balance to strike there's no
simple answers and we won't find them
all today because this will be an
ongoing process without going into the
details that Margaret already outlined
and my colleagues will expand on I would
like just to infuse a few points
first we cannot prescribe when country a
for example or be decides to open up for
tourism
member states will progressively lift
border restrictions this will happen
gradually and not all at once that
reflects the different situation of
course in each of our countries and we
need to accept it but second we are
helping member states and businesses to
get prepared member states need to have
sufficient capacities in terms of
hospitals testing surveillance contact
tracings the hospitality sector needs to
know what has protocols they will need
to comply with and what material they
will need to welcome guests this
includes of course very practical things
like cleaning and disinfecting
frequently twisted surfaces providing
masks having spare rooms for potential
contaminated guests and so on this will
of course reassure to it that they are
safe and they can choose their
destination within the you knowing that
they will find the same level of
precaution and preparedness and that
they will not be discriminated against
wherever they come from in the EU that's
very important so financial risk is also
an element that we need to mitigate and
by which I already mentioned it that is
the logic behind our recommendation and
Winchell's as an alternative to cash for
investment and for our citizens and
businesses need information that is why
we are setting up as Mehcad said a
dedicated website with map combining
real-time information related to tourism
the way job could be called for example
reopening
you because it is what we want smoothly
what we want we open you and this will
also help businesses draw inspirations
from innovative solutions fun by others
because ultimately to manage this virus
Europe needs creativity we have seen
that innovation and responsibility among
the many businesses that have converted
for examples are production lines to put
to produce mask or ventilators and we
are starting to see that innovation
among small restaurant and hotel owners
as well as town's frequency all over all
over all over Europe beyond managing
what will remain difficult 2020 summer
season we need to start preparing the
future as far as all other industrial
ecosystem the recovery will have to be
green digital and resilient we need to
work collectively EU institutions to
industry regions and cities stakeholders
on how to achieve this learning from the
crisis paying particular attention to
SMEs anticipating new trends and
consumer patterns related to it
therefore we will organize European
Tour's convention to start designing the
European choice of tomorrow and start
preparing a world map for sustainable
innovative and resilient European to his
ecosystem in in other words a European
agenda photo is 2050 so that we will
emerge hopefully stronger from this
crisis thank you thank you very much to
both of you for your introductory
remarks we now move to questions I would
just like to remind everybody that for
this press conference we have eight
languages available German English
French Italian Danish and
Spanish you can select the audio channel
just above the video screen in front of
you so we now move to Oliver Grimm for
the first question Oliver we give you
the floor go ahead do you hear me
absolute do you hear me hello super
wonderful hi Oliver came with your
stream newspaper he plays a show
question to vice president vest Ollie
you mentioned the issue of compensation
for travelers whose holidays were
canceled we heard yesterday from your
own services that about 12 member states
are already in breach of the current
consumer protection law and that there
might be more member states my question
is do you intend to start infringement
procedures against these countries
against these Member States and if so
would these be expedited speeded up
procedures given that this is money that
is very important to families all over
Europe families that might have lost the
jobs in the meantime and you need
basically every hero to to gets alongs
and who can't actually be satisfied with
a voucher for a for a holiday they that
they probably couldn't take anyway thank
you well that is it that is exactly why
we insist that each citizen have a right
here because we cannot judge on the
economic situation of the individual if
you have lost your job if this is your
entire holiday budgets for for
travelling that sits in these tickets
that you cannot use anymore then you
would need to have the refund and this
is why we say this is your rights full
stop at the same time there is a
liquidity crunch if one can afford to
take a voucher or would like to support
the businesses by taking an archer well
this can be made attractive that can be
that you for instance if you don't use
it within a year that you can redeem it
and have cash back that it's a very
flexible voucher that you maybe get an
additional service on top of taking the
voucher there are a number of different
ways to
do that if if the member state wants to
guarantee the voucher obviously we stand
ready to process such a scheme as of
today where we have taken the Commission
decision to this letters will be sent to
the member states who are in breach of
this very fundamental principle so these
letters they are going off as we speak
thank you thank you we now move to David
carita ideologically yes hello can you
hear me yes we can
okay thank you very much David Coretta
radically sorry to insist on the issue
of passenger rides because you are not
opening an infringement procedure if my
understanding is is right you are just
sending letters so in this moment the
airlines are benefiting from state aids
my question is quite simple is the
liquidity problem of ireland's company
more important than the liquidity
problem of households because that's the
impression that we received from the
attitude of the European Commission and
some member states if the European
Commission do not does not act
immediately on that issue in the same
question for Luca mr. Brito who put the
D frontier in apado commendation
cientific DeSoto Hopa do control
prevention
seola montien the control of frontier
Olli frontier fermitas confettis confirm
a la di di papa firmly frontier remain
avodat info level a todos more
progressive mine cetera me circle
Basanti fish food Itza paavo did pass on
primo la frontiere Santa will kill for
combat leverage mercy
well on the first question I'm terribly
sorry that was unclear what is starting
now is the first step in the
infringement procedure it is always so
that the first thing we do is that we
send a letter to say well you're not in
agreement with European legislation and
then of course we expect the Member
State to correct it immediately
otherwise the next steps will be taken
thank you you will have a precise
explanation on the policy that we will
at the protocols that will present with
our colleagues Eva Johnson in few
minutes but but you know first we need
to understand that of course we have the
borders and restriction on travel should
first be lifted in areas with a
continuously improving epidemic legal
situation and where sufficient
capabilities are in place in terms of
hospitals as I said testings
surveillance and contact tracing
capacities and this is the first
priorities and this is of course a
decision of the hell's or sororities
which are run as you know by member
states but secondly and of course we
will try of course as we said to to
coordinate orgies and my colleagues will
be much more vocal on this but the
second thing I wanted to mention is that
obviously you're right in a sense there
is no border for the virus and this is
why we will always prefer to see zones
areas region where of course you will
you may we may see an evolution or
different evolution of the pandemics and
then of course to treat these regions
the way that should be treated and this
is of course what we will recommend more
and more to look at regions instead of
looking at countries but I will treat
decision
we'll have been taken yes go ahead
okay
[Music]
[Music]
so Fiona Susan Chuck Lord they will meet
and be fed into a commissions Sam the
interfering be adverse to delay become
shown smooth or at the end lost enter
failing air I can send the TPA Oakland
some chili plate only say mas cerca de
verte Thomas Kasim do personal civilians
who had captured cheats risk-averse on
his protocol Apple s Savina Veronica
meant men was an be failing at a
consonant a lift for lend her a no known
each saddle it's what moment caphis
partisan this message
Savita Houska he'd spare the constable
Nobles to say our students astonishment
is a t get the Sun dismissive because it
hurt a consonant Lobos of
irreversibility player opener what is
moody fatigue they are in fundamental
check for you pea
ethnic a hardflip avail puts versa
console
thank you very much we now move to Jo
Velasquez are you hearing me not only do
we hear you we see you yay go
oui merci beaucoup anesthetic example
developed in Kyoto know what her
comunicación a double blow always who
took also capitalism
schema markup is a dimensionless
quantity was of curvature default air if
a McKinsey passive wash they did have a
earth he controlled it Roger
German model quite a passive or assist a
prison that you as cassis of to LA do
ratio similar that when we video music
so could be wind would he always wanna
win the boat or it Makati yeah solid
miss effect II want sec please so set in
lemon see Danielle over 1000 cool
we say to increased Ovid mi pop-tart
Ikeda pass via not only Ricardo do to
Isfahan me on Polly be the model to
reach miss patty to pour led like a
stroke of oppose a get absolutely my son
she'll be necessity Fatima the world is
a cooperative o último mmm
is he a fake book would lead especially
awesome mo avec le chef data in the
Google memo concern a polyp I don't
normally know certifies reckon idea
don't settle physical isolation cell
pour etre bailiff also frontally if we
arrest Lee shows objective Mossad father
similar way as they happen more suicide
case yo Pacific
specific model Arab elephant rally
miscible Julieta not Westridge a token
ski no concern
servo hua hua envision global port with
a unique ma Paula Teresa
also up la vie de ma decision presented
types canal going for envision orgasm
all out of El Cholo you the ski suit
pass super vehicle issues similar
response Calvin's Emilio
doli doli sermon given for a little
problem katha problem F of tau Google
over damaja du marché Ontario messy poor
hotel will go like a mission with faith
positio also key concern Lavie demuccio
the config mo no passage different here
politically or trans mentally etc lapaki
heated up to genre concern specific more
like a twisted missing body according to
some puzzle creepy disordered emotional
problem in person not know a Thomas
Molina
thank you very much Tomas Medina swiss
television some people like to go on
holiday because of crowds and some
regions of Europe certain beaches
certain islands they actually catered to
this kind of people who like big crowds
now I don't mean to criticize where I
was reading your documents and halfway
through it I my I will to go on holiday
was lost if I was this kind of person so
I wonder whether you're considering this
kind of psychological impact especially
for for this kind of tourism if you have
something to say to this well you
actually have first informed you're
welcome to criticize so don't feel sorry
about that but I think you're right to
say that if you travel for crowds this
will be a very difficult summer I think
still in every member states they would
say only so many people can come
together until end of maybe August you
shouldn't have
big gatherings actually we also
recommend that technology is used in
order to enable people to see how to
process for instance to a museum in a
safe way to buy your tickets beforehand
so you don't have to queue at a counter
that your tickets can be processed
without a a professional at the museum
having to come close to you so that you
have your booked entry in order to avoid
crowds
and that that kind of systems can be
used in numerous different places in
order to be able to respect distance
between people so I think I think you're
right if you travel for crowds this will
be a difficult summer nothing to add it
was very well said we we need to
understand and know that you know that
extremely well the crisis is not over
we are just lifting now a little bit
more our freedom could encode but we
need to continue to live with the virus
so yes Margaret said it very well this
will be a summer like the others but we
hope it will be the last one this way ok
thank you very much we now move to
Daniel Vibha Daniel from the
Luxembourgish Public Radio 100.7 I have
a follow-up to David's question in maybe
a more general way I'd like to know
what's the Commission's general position
on closing borders in order to fight a
virus like corona that's my first
question and I have a second one on
discrimination the Communist Commission
has been underlying that EU citizens
should not be discriminated if I
understand you recommend any
recommendation well this could be the
case though that a citizen of a country
is allowed to enter another member state
but in other citizen from another
country it's not allowed to do so so how
how is this not discriminatory thank you
first and foremost our colleague in
value Hanson who has worked with with
borders now for a very long time and who
have the interaction with the relevant
ministers she will be here shortly just
to say that she will give you every
detail but the point to say here is that
if you open the ball
well it shouldn't be yes for some
passport holders and not for other
passport holders because you can have
you know completely the legitimate
reasons to be in a country you can work
there you can have your family there you
have stayed there for a very long time
even though you do not have the passport
of the country and then when borders are
lifted well you should not be prevented
from going and as Shelly just mentioned
the virus doesn't really respect the
national borders that were created by
the wars in previous centuries the virus
travels with people if we do not do as
we are supposed to do sanitize keep a
distance that we are prudent and this is
much more important for people to
understand you see the the approach in
France with red and green zones you see
in other countries larger countries
where regions have have had a very very
awful situation with the virus and other
parts of the country has not bit hits at
all
so so that is I think that is the
important balance to be kept here that
you Smith should be specific about the
virus and not about the old borders and
the Commission has been consistent in in
our guidance to member states to say
well borders should be lifted for
workers for travellers while at the same
time obviously the safety and the health
of people are being the first and
foremost concern thank you we now move
to criminal especially because
well I I really do not mean to escape
the question but I don't think that is
fair when my colleague is coming here
who will have to take the the precise
decisions decisions on what to do on
these issues and and Allah will be here
in depending on the number of questions
but very very shortly indeed you will
have ample opportunity I see that there
are many many rounds raised to ask
specific questions on the on the
guidelines and the different aspects
including vultures consumer rights in
the second press conference let's see if
we have a certain number of questions
perhaps more on the economic dimension
of this I move to Susanna faxes I thank
you but I still have a question on
vouchers actually I would like to
understand sorry if a company decides
that it will only give this money back
to to to a customer in - for instance in
two years time is it still okay that's
that's my concrete question and you're
saying that of course we cannot have
crowds but should we expect crowds
inside the planes because we don't see
here or at least I don't see here a
clear recommendations for empty seats so
I would like to understand for a VA
Sheehan what is your recommendation and
just one last question because we saw
Greece suggesting that suggesting that
actually a passenger or tourist should
take should be tested so 74 hours
earlier the traveling and we don't see
any kind of recommendation in the sense
so this is something that for the
Commission is still not feasible thank
you well let me give you short answers
just as a precursor to my colleagues who
will be coming here first in in two
years time that is that is not what is
supposed to happen if you want to have
your money back when you have the right
to get your money back
that's the first thing second on
Airlines we give the guidance as to how
from a health point of view that you can
still fly safely where you cannot
observe a distance that you then use
different kinds of protective equipment
masks in particular and of course that
you use the ventilation system to its
utmost use on the question of testing
before at borders where what we have
learned from the health professionals in
this case is that you do not have sort
of evidence to say that this is a secure
way to know that people may not have
been infected or have not been infected
after they have taken the test which is
why it is not part of our
recommendations before moving on to the
[Music]
more fancy clothes fancy casual music
traditional Moe Asch be honored on the
day Hong Kong's amount of colophon
stampeded future can have exceed the
power be no ghost no ghost on watch you
organ in Spain Portugal Italy in sacred
situation epidemiological Fonzie distant
cetera confident dose on Prakash a
peaceful contest innovation policy
regime elephant's the way Jota Rubio
Joseph concerto across the city to us
remedy music as compared with the
control mo s ki Fateh novo total number
Kevin here with confirmer Jimmy Sam
Freeman block a reserved very accepting
resume commerce company machinists
mechanic director de fronteira campy
casa specificity in mendoza mistresses
formal investiture
for smoke because until recently proved
awfully busy tunics positions with
pivotal mini laughs and Madhavi a
vanilla phantom Ariana Tom a restless
performer is irrational to talk if it is
indeed an imam or Pony Express machinery
powers gone means less feminine Vista
graphic a celeb Pony era with a resolve
the force it attended compy to a stick
the European Mitte unique moment of all
a horse like a book with twists no
somebody did we have consumed the
original fancy la fossa to see Sumatra
say no Thermopylae by example nice panel
kita dugeun hampi twisting video of the
tree Iliad Rizzo with a video rest
this is Alyssa Tweety Espanola solo the
accommodation did you treated salty it's
insisted she was on with ecological
reserve and to waste it on a span to add
content temple of khonsu
doesnot was specific evacuate the mall
at the National you will su super not
consciously Kamsa you Audrey Jonesy pass
successfully car Saturday mr. Ricca
ocean with a rosca de France some
educational subsribe the Moses ug
concern like the residue no fancy will
opinion of us in the path that the month
yet the Madiba example twenty
espanol Tokugawa stood upon a vida mo
the situatio epidemiologic don't do
Shakur
the Zetas mom don't Adri editor promote
Olivet KC on a Ferrari or a villa Medusa
the first so suppose actual is exited
the presentation initial the data
ongoing process
yeseo Chaudhary of hoop resort the
protocol present-day accommodation you
want a featherbed with terrain avoid the
mill tip is interaction Abuk to
determine the trajectory model due to
visa menus a vocal supporter calvo
progressive more evil away adapt a
second saxophone from a villa ma sucah
new present on odd we don't impose a bad
case John sicko so Lafosse community
will in a patio restriction
convalescence it when I addressed the
pop enigma open Mozilla Schengen the
move service which only copied on
policies way veneer on France sunset
will get shown the accountant for $1
billion poker don't whereas comedy road
we saw said question so let's do them
case from Fukui difficile hospice kilala
a Memphis Tiger dibs president with
Elias apologies that obviously one of
the most difficult questions that those
who seems to be the easiest one because
I don't know the answer to your question
because I don't know what they are
thinking and planning in in Switzerland
two perspectives one is of course that a
lot of museums either prolong their
exhibitions or they postpone the opening
of exhibitions I myself happily took a
voucher to be able to come back to Paris
to see the big exhibition in Kampala on
Pompeii because obviously that couldn't
open and we couldn't come
during the confinement so you could hope
that they would do that in Swiss alone
and the second perspective is of course
that some of us may not be able to go to
the shows that we wanted to see the
exhibition's that ran out and we
couldn't go there I think much more
important is to recognize all the many
people who now see businesses that they
have built over decades just to crumble
and this is of course why we have this
drive to say if it can be done safely if
each and one of us ourselves can take an
informed decision as to whether we will
trav
not well then we should do it but we all
take a risk we do our outlets to
minimize that risk we see have
governments businesses regional
governments they do their best to
minimize the risk to make sure that we
can travel healthy and safely but we all
have to take our own informed decision
and I myself very much hope that we will
open up I have the same discussion I
think as many of you have over the
dining tables can we go this summer
where can we go this summer because
after this confinement we need a break
and all the many many people working in
tourism they are eager to welcome us
back thank you very much we'll take one
last question from Veronica Phil it's
from wife Veronica
press your microphone you have muted it
on your side okay then if that's not
that doesn't work we will take one last
question from Paula Paula Tama hello
can you hear me yes hi thank you my
question is for vice president
investigate
to which questions to which countries
has a letter of formal notice being sent
over infringement of passenger rights
please oh I am sorry I should have wrote
that list I don't know we can provide
you with with information about this
this question after this press
conference okay thank you very much
thank you to both our members of the
college for their presence today we now
move to the second press conference so
stay tuned thank you